two years ago some unhappy t1 fans sent
a truck to their team's headquarters
with messages on it lambasting the org
for what they felt was a gross
mismanagement of the team at the time
recently this past week they've started
doing it again and all of this comes at
a time when t1 have been asking fans
even those with good intentions to
please stay away from players houses
it's another bizarre t1 story let's get
into it
all right then just before we talk about
t1 it's time to remind you guys that we
are so
excruciatingly close to two million
subscribers if you're watching this and
you've thought about subscribing but
you've never quite got around to it
please consider subscribing we are so
close now and you could help us get
there thanks okay so a few weeks ago i
shared the news that faker was suing
some of his toxic fans leaving him
malicious images and comments online on
july 19th faker's legal team apex law
spoke to press in south korea to
announce they had filed a lawsuit
against those who have written malicious
comments against faker online faker's
lawyers described the content he'd been
sent as unspeakably foul but in the past
t1 has been subjected to behavior which
can be better categorized as just weird
in that video i touched on one famous
example of this there was an incident in
which some t1 fans circled around the
headquarters of skt the parent company
of t1 to protest among other things the
potential hiring of new team management
the message board on their truck
lambasted t1 for hiring famed league
coach and personality ls who they
described as a coach who would cause
public controversy at the time this
specific stunt felt like a bit of a
one-off we've seen fans in korea do some
pretty strange things when criticizing
their teams especially t1 fans but
nothing quite like this well last week i
definitely wondered if people had been
digging up old pictures from that event
when i saw images being circulated that
looked extremely similar to the ones
from 2020 but no it's happened again on
august 4th angry t1 fans once again
hired an led truck to protest about t1's
coaching staff this time it stood in
front of the t1 building and then moved
on towards lol park the theater where
the regular season lck games are played
ahead of t1's match against hanwha live
esports this is the truck outside lol
park people take pictures of it
i don't know what it says
the truck is just parked on the road
outside lol park i guess it's in here
invent global translated the various
images on display one red incompetent
head coach relegation team coach
admitted lack of ability the solution is
to sign a coach that has experienced
winning worlds the seven years of glory
made by skt fans leave from three years
of incompetence another message said
appoint a high-level former player
coaching staff that the t1 players
deserve performance going backward
unqualified coaches who don't even
prepare for matches we've had enough
there was also players spend time
analyzing the other team while coaches
play friendly games when the league is
in progress who is the coach and finally
we don't need an incompetent coaching
staff that doesn't even know the draft
sign proven former player coaches now
clearly this is all a bit vague if
you're only just learning about it so
what exactly are these fans unhappy
about with t1's coaches well last month
t1's largest korean fan community shared
an open letter to t1 on a site called dc
inside which is not too dissimilar to
reddit and part of it was aimed
specifically at moment one of the team's
coaches they criticized him for having
only previously played and coached in
lower divisions including a quote
dishonorable demotion as coach of jin
air green wings where the team finished
their 29 season with a famous one win
and 35 loss record discussing more
recent events the letter addressed t1's
loss to rng at msi 2022 finals they
described his pick and ban strategy as
quote advantage donating and that not
only did he let down two million fans in
the process but that his pick and ban
strategy's instability has not improved
since then honestly i could keep going
here large portions of this open letter
were dedicated to just ripping into
moment demanding he answers their
questions and suggesting that he's
incapable of getting them to worlds this
year head coach polt didn't escape
criticism either of course in this
letter paul has been catching flack from
some t1 fans since he was hired back in
2020. in fact he was a sizeable part of
the reason that unhappy t1 fans sent the
original truck to the skt headquarters
the first time the t1 head coach was
once a starcraft 2 pro back in the day
before moving into the world of team
fight tactics clearly this guy knows
strategy but some t1 fans couldn't
accept a coach with little to no
experience in league of legends and to
be honest they haven't really got off
his back about it since despite the
team's resurgence over the past year
that he has directly overseen one word
you'll notice that comes up a lot in
criticism of t1's coaching staff by fans
is worlds it's a really big deal for
them now some of you guys may already
know i'm a tsm fan and honestly these
days i'm happy to just even make
playoffs i don't have a very high bar at
all at the moment but for t1 fans it's a
bit different with three worlds titles
and two msi titles under their belt t1
fans have rightly or wrongly come to
expect a different pedigree from their
team granted it's been a fair few years
since they won either of those
tournaments but no team has been able to
surpass their international trophy
counts since and t1 fans would like to
keep it that way the monstrous
record-breaking spring split they just
had hasn't been enough to keep the
critics at bay faker and his four
extremely talented young team-mates
should have been able to silence any
haters after not losing a single series
to any other korean team for the first
half of 2022 many teams would be happy
with that but it just ain't worlds i
guess so the first time these t1 fans
sent these message boards was back in
2020 the second time was on august 4th
and then as i was looking into that it
happened again on august 7th the trucks
had similar messages to before as
translated by inven global this one read
there's no need for incompetent coaches
that don't even know how to draft
appoint former player coaches that have
already proven themselves performers
going backward unqualified coaches who
don't even prepare for matches we've had
enough at this point i just want to
remind everyone that t1 are currently 14
and 2 in the lck in fact those two
losses are the only domestic lck losses
they've had all year so far they've
definitely not looked as dominant as
they were in spring but yeah i think
that's an important piece of context to
keep in mind another message read
scarecrow head coach polt
sabotaging moment take responsibility
and resign another said incompetent head
coach relegation team coach admitted
lack of ability the solution is to sign
a coach that has experienced winning
worlds the seven years of glory made by
skt fans leave from three years of
incompetence the notion of hiring
coaches that specifically have
experience of winning worlds is
something that comes up a lot in these
stunts and open letters to t1 t1 ceo joe
marsh addressed this directly last week
saying 100 fans wasted money on a truck
they don't speak for the other 1 million
fans you failed to mention we had
world's winning coaches in 2020 and 2021
one didn't make worlds and the other was
replaced mid-season just thought the
full context would be helpful to the
readers like i touched on before
demanding a coach that has literally
taken home the greatest trophy league of
legends has to offer might seem a little
crazy to fans of other teams but this
minority of t1 fans and they are a
minority expect nothing less than the
absolute best for t1 to me it kind of
feels like the elephant in the room
might be their legendary former coach
coma this guy oversaw the team's golden
era some give him as much credit as
faker himself for t1 success over those
years he was an absolute cornerstone for
them and then he left to go and coach
their rivals dan 1 gaming and yeah it
feels like some t1 fans never really got
over his departure look there really is
some unhinged fan behavior going on in
south korea's league of legends scene at
the moment i talked about it extensively
in faker's lawsuit video and while i
don't want to diminish any criticisms of
these message board trucks they do feel
slightly more bizarre than abusive we
did have some more serious news from t1
just yesterday where they asked fans who
were waiting around at their
headquarters and players houses to keep
their distance and respect their privacy
they asked fans to not go to the
player's houses at all and ask them to
limit contact with the players because
of covid and in order to create a safe
fan slash player culture so the message
board trucks are they going to work i
doubt it are they the tip of a much
uglier iceberg of t1s fandom perhaps
only time will tell in an interview with
korean outlet osun translated by mr
rumor on twitter faker himself addressed
the message board trucks saying whatever
fans do it starts from the love towards
the team everyone in t1 should do harder
to repay the love the fans give us i
will do my best for the fans one thing
i'm interested to see is what happens
after worlds if t1 wins it and that's
not completely unrealistic will the
weird fan behavior calm down if they
lose it will we see more of these
message board trucks or perhaps a
protest that's even more intense
something tells me this isn't the end of
them
it's interesting because in esports it
feels really weird that you have fans
making these demands it's
fairly common in at least english
football fan bases will make demands of
their owners or they will straight up
call for the owners to just leave or to
sell the club they truly believe that
like the club belongs to the fans and
any owners or coaches are just temporary
custodians but in esports it's just like
whoa you know just sit back and watch it
right